when just cause 3 launched back in
December developer Avalanche Studios
also gave the option for their air land
and sea expansion paths and now we're
about to experience the air portion of
that pass with sky fortress the first
expansion coming to Just Cause 3
remember Rico's wingsuit and of course
you do well sky fortress adds a new
mechanized Bavarian wingsuit and it
sounds like you're going to need it the
expansion tasks you with saving metaji
from an army of robotic drones speaking
of which you'll also get a personal
defense drone plus a Bavarian splitter
assault rifle both of those can be used
in the base game as well and of course
the expansion adds plenty of new
missions and challenges sky fortress is
due out in March we don't know what's
next from the air land and sea pass but
i'm gonna guess it involves land and the
sea anyway that expansion pass will cost
you 25 bucks if you still want to grab
it and it'll get you into the sky
fortress content a week early and if you
want to stay up to date on all that just
cause 3 has to offer y'all ready in the
right place
you